- All right y'all,
(audience cheers)
let's close out with just
a little more holiday joy.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
A Washington D.C. baker
recently got the early Christmas gift
he had been waiting for.
Kareem, also known as Mr. Bake,
was just named as a James
Beard Award semi-finalist
for outstanding pastry chef or baker.
So amazing.
(audience applauds)
He's the first queer Black
man to actually earn the honor
and we have him on the line right now.
Everybody say hello to Mr. Bake
watching on NBC4 Washington.
(audience cheers and applauds)
What's up, Mr. Bake?
- Hey Kelly!
How you doing, girlfriend?
- Well, congrats.
You the best smile ever, oh my gosh.
So, congratulations.
This is a long time coming, right?
- Absolutely, Kelly.
Listen here, girlfriend.
I have been baking since
I was eight years old,
and it has been a journey.
And I am super excited
to be leading the path
for open more Black men in baking.
I don't know if you know, Kelly,
but statistics are in America now,
there is about what,
10% Black men who bake
and about 9% who identify with queer.
So I'm super excited to be
leading this charge, girlfriend.
- Yeah!
(audience cheers)
I love, with that smile.
Well, you're doing a special fundraiser
for the LGBTQ+ community for the holidays,
so tell everybody about it.
- Oh my God, yes, yes, yes.
So, I'm partnering up with one
of the largest organizations
here in Washington D.C.
called Us Helping Us.
And they service the youth,
adults, and homelessness,
HIV/AIDS, mental health, you name it,
they've probably got the help for you.
We are partnering up to bring
a gingerbread competition
where we will give them pre-made
gingerbreads and supplies
and they have to decorate them in teams.
So, it's about team
building and expression.
- Yeah, I love working as a team.
(audience applauds)
So wait, I hear that you have
a gingerbread house there, right?
- Oh, girlfriend.
You already know it.
- I, oh my gosh!
(audience cheers)
Okay.
Okay, sir.
I have a few of those
in my house right now
and they do not look like that.
(all laughing)
Thank you so much Mr.
Bake, congratulations!
- Thank you, happy holidays!
- I'm liking your post
right now.
(bell dinging)
And that's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like you, sir.
So they are gonna give Us
Helping Us $1,000 to help out.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Thank you!
- Oh my God, I love you so much.
You've gotta come visit us in person!
Thank you so much for joining us
and thank you to all our guests this hour.
Barry Manilow, Teddy Swims,
Lauren, Zarian, and Josiah.
Y'all have a great day, and if
it's not, try and change it.